Vicki where is your I thought up in
Compton California yes and talking about
here with Charlie
okay my childhood illis know
again we lost AJ he started his age of
six when my father saw my last
which I was b-team
my mother asked me about it at the age
of teen I lied and I told her no because
I don't want to keep taking but from us
for my whole sisters and brothers to be
taking from her to about to me so I told
her no he never had been so at the age
of 25 I had a child by my father
I was drunk when the other party came
home from the club I mean from the club
and I was sleep when I woke up and they
have no penny time and I never knew I
had and I got pregnant by myself and
check to date I started looking at him
he's just like my father stop thinking
about father would break me without
sleep
it's uh my son asked me but I like to
look photographer
but I do believe it's my father's that
having sex with yes
I think we're doing it didn't yes I
started get paid by having sex with him
for money
yes that will maybe turn to prostitution
a drugs like I use drugs to the Dufner
pain about the decline but I talk about
it
the only one day no my brother at the
age of 12 molested me
I did my uncle even lets me a date
my two-year-old I'll wager he passed
away 30 years later
I applied to a Viking father I know for
one it's my oldest child
I don't know but as today I look at him
he does look like my father
I left home at the age of 17
you can got here on the scale
well bit down here well I had a fiance
me that we got into it he must be my
head with a crane so two years ago I was
down here for two years I had housing
but somewhat live he said I pull a knife
on you and it wasn't true could we had
shared humility you know share kitchens
bathrooms just like he likes happenin I
father became the Courtney lights I lost
my project
get our banquet of
like say the base of Exeter
[Music]
but other side is 28a youngest sheets
are 24
sorry race day tonight I sleep in a tent
I have a tip of town street okay good
since the ager rabid on PCP from the age
of 13 there was an earthquake where
wonderful age of 13 PC people the age of
18 10 20 and then I stopped
but crack okay was the hardest to get
offer what the programs but he didn't
work I stopped over here on my own that
which I believe I hate I was a shut us
down for whole year straight but when I
got my housing I started back and I have
never started smoking crack since I got
you
every day between
every day
that's not
kids learn about just thank God
otherwise kids artichokes smoke
cigarettes have to drink nothing they
all there are good kids they got a good
job
once I was what ups my daughter's a
social worker I'm gonna travel them in
Los Angeles I did 5 to 20 days in
college and they're by other side he
just bought of a home and here you got
it's all business even have a restaurant
no
they take away my place
do you would he serious
to be honest with you I fell I put up a
picture I wanna know studies get off
with joy completely give me apartment
and they erase the wedding they give
their house but hopefully I've made it
to see that
use your and I also want to see be able
to rely with my kids
physically Stella Facebook I lost my
mother and I poor but my father he's
still here
them I don't talk to any of my family I
just left everyone like you I just lost
all well a little cut check my facebook
yeah but for us like seeing a place of
things
with your father maybe saving
I forgave my father for what he did I'm
forgiven so I don't want to go to him
and I forgave you what we do to me I
dance my life so it's forbidden that
they think about it I try to stay away
from
you are good thank you